bienvenido al mercado de las vegas
the boulevard mall has added a culinary
and cultural vacation to the community
and i got to check it out take a look
the boulevard mall is the oldest mall in
nevada if you didn't know that but it's
bringing something very new to the
community timo thank you for having us
sure welcome to the boulevard thank you
so we're in the mercado which means
marketplace and spanish define that for
us
sure a lot of latin american countries
the marketplaces like at the city center
next to the church and people do their
shopping there anything and everything
they might need
is all done in one trip that's awesome
and what can we expect in
our local mercado here we have over 100
unique family owned small businesses
that sell any of those arts and crafts
type of things
food and any kind of unique gifts that
you might need
and what was the process like bringing
this to the community
i mean why does vegas need this well i
think this started brewing in like 2016
when we realized that the uh mall
business was changing
uh big department stores were were not
doing so well and then
we wanted to bring something that would
bring a lot of traffic and bring an
experience to the community where you
could come and
find unique gifts and i feel like it
also bridges cultures together it
exposes people to new things
absolutely you can come through here and
talk to a lot of these shop owners learn
a lot
and you can buy a product that has a lot
of history behind it definitely and
how can people shop in the mercado and
in the boulevard mall safely these days
uh well first i'll say that our cleaning
procedures here are paramount to
anything that i've ever seen
but i also will if as you can see these
wide hallways allow for social
distancing
and we take all the precautions and i
think it's a
very safe place to shop yeah and
everyone's looking for you know a
vacation
somewhere to go and this is the perfect
place absolutely
you could spend a lot of time here
there's a lot of things to see and right
now
we're coming into our food court
which will have 13 restaurants that are
all unique latin american flavors
uh and and we'll and this will sure to
be a hit
oh absolutely i can already smell the
food
so i cannot wait to see this hustling
and bustling
throughout the week so thank you so much
for having us absolutely we'll be back
to see
the food court when it's ready we look
forward to welcoming you back
thank you el mercado is located in the
west main lobby of boulevard mall for
more information just call 702-735-7430
or just visit elmercattolv.com